hey this is pressure Locker consider a
square whose side length is equal to one
you pick two points at random and
calculate the distance between those
points what is the average value of the
distance when you pick points at random
naturally sometimes the points will be
very far apart other times the two
points will be much closer together the
question is given all the different ways
that you can pick two points at random
what will the average distance be
between the two points give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for the solution will
approach the problem analytically we'll
place the unit square in the Cartesian
plane we can give each of the two points
an x and y coordinate to figure out the
distance between the two points we
consider the difference of the x
coordinates in the difference of the Y
coordinates these are the distances of
the legs of a right triangle therefore
we can use the Pythagorean theorem and
come up with the distance formula for
the distance between the two points this
will be the square root of the sum of
the squared differences between the x
and the y coordinates so how will we
figure out the average value of this
function the first method I'll present
is we can generate random numbers for
our coordinates come up with a distance
and then take the average over many
trials the next method I'll present is
we'll get an exact answer with integrals
so let's first come up with an estimate
let's estimate our answer numerically we
want to generate four coordinates the x
and y coordinates for the first point
and the x and y coordinates for the
second point in each trial we'll compute
the distance between these two points
we'll then take the average over many
trials we can generate a random
coordinate between 0 and 1 using the
rand function which generates a random
number between 0 and 1
in each trial we'll take the distance by
calculating the square root of the
difference of the x coordinates squared
and then adding it to the difference of
the y-coordinates squared this will give
us an distance in one trial we'll copy
this down over 10,000 trials and now we
can figure out the average by taking the
average over all of these trials so
we'll take the average distance over
10,000 trials and this will give us an
estimate of point five two we figured
out our answer is about 0.5 - but what
is it exactly let's figure out using
integrals we could naively try and
integrate the distance function over its
domain but we'll end up with a quadruple
integral which will not be tractable in
order to figure out this integral we
will have to do several clever
substitutions the first thing we'll do
is we'll reduce the number of
independent variables instead of
considering each coordinate we'll only
consider the distances in the X
direction and the y direction we have
the absolute value of Delta X and the
absolute value of Delta Y will consider
distances between 0 & 1
we can rewrite our distance formula in
terms of Delta X and Delta Y before we
integrate it we have to take into
account that Delta X and Delta Y will
have different distributions than the
standard uniform distribution originally
each of our coordinates was drawn from a
uniform distribution which had a
probability density function of 1 we now
want the absolute value of the
difference between two standard uniform
distributions this is well-known to be a
triangular distribution we end up with a
double integral in our probability
density function we have two factors of
two which come out to be a
factor of four we then have the distance
formula in terms of the X&Y distances
and then we have the 1 minus x times 1
minus y to take into account the
probability density functions so now how
do we figure out this double integral
we're going to make a change into polar
coordinates well let x equals R cosine
theta and y equals R sine theta instead
of integrating over the whole unit
square we'll only integrate over the
lower half triangle and then we'll
double the value of this integral the
angle theta ranges between 0 and the
45-degree line so theta ranges between 0
and PI over 4 next we want to know the
range of the radius R R starts out as 0
and it will range depending on the angle
theta since the base of this triangle is
always 1 the value for R will be 1
divided by cosine of theta which is also
equal to secant theta we can now rewrite
our integral we have to remember that
we're only integrating over the lower
half so we want to double the value of
the integral we also want to remember
that we have an extra factor of R when
we change into polar coordinates so our
polar coordinates integral will look
something like the following double
integral we have the extra factor of 2
because we're only integrating over the
lower half and then we're going to
rewrite our distance function and
density function in terms of polar
coordinates which we then multiply by R
and then we have D Rd theta we also have
our new limits of integration so now
let's go ahead and substitute and try
and figure out this integral we input
our polar coordinates for the for the
distance function and for the
probability densities we can then
simplify this we have R squared cosine
squared of theta plus R squared sine
squared of theta this will simplify to
be just R squared because cosine squared
of theta plus sine squared of theta is
equal to 1 so our entire square root
ends of just being R we have technically
the absolute value of R but we're only
dealing with positive R so it just ends
up being R
we can expand this out and we have a
polynomial in terms of our this will not
be too hard to compute well substitute
in our limits of integration and it
simplifies tremendously into one single
integral so now we have to integrate
over theta this is actually a fun little
integral the secant cubed of theta is
the famous integral and I provided a
link in the video description I'll just
go ahead and use the formula here we now
substitute in our limits of integration
and we end up with the following result
when all is said and done two plus the
square root of two plus five times the
natural log of square root of two plus 1
all over 15 and this is approximately
0.5 to 1 which is very similar to what
we got in the spreadsheet did you figure
it out thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math and game theory you can
catch run on my blog mind your decisions
which you can follow on Facebook Google+
and patreon you can catch me on social
media at pressure Walker and if you
liked the video please check out my
books there are links in the video
description